en este vídeo vamos a analizar las
curvas de oferta y demanda del mercado
de chocolate pero intentaremos
comprenderlas de una manera un poco
distinta en particular para la curva de
demanda hablaremos de la ganancia
marginal del consumidor cuando nos
referimos al concepto de marginal en
realidad nos estamos preguntando qué
sucede con la ganancia del consumidor
con cada pequeño extra que consumimos es
decir cuál es el beneficio que obtengo
al consumir más chocolate para este caso
bien desde el punto de vista del mercado
imaginemos que no hubiera chocolate sino
gente en el mercado que tiene antojo de
chocolate que sueña con el chocolate si
de pronto pudieran poner en sus manos un
poco de chocolate obtendrían una enorme
ganancia de esa cantidad creciente de
chocolate podemos cuantificar la
ganancia en términos de pesos y tal vez
para esas personas
el precio razonable a su muy grande
deseo de chocolate es de 50 pesos por
kilo podemos decir que están dispuestos
a pagar 50 pesos porque obtienen una
ganancia pero si pagan menos de 50 pesos
por ejemplo 10 pesos
entonces están obteniendo 40 pesos de
ganancia extra una especie de excedente
del consumidor derivado de poder obtener
chocolate a un precio más bajo que el de
la ganancia marginal del consumidor pero
supongamos que se pone a disposición de
esas personas más chocolate a la gente
les sigue gustando pero su necesidad su
antojo por el chocolate ya está saciado
entonces como en la mayoría de los
mercados la ganancia marginal del
consumidor tiende a disminuir a medida
que la cantidad consumida aumenta una
manera de entenderlo es si tenemos una
pequeña cantidad inicial aquí vamos a
llamar la cantidad delta y la
multiplicamos por la ganancia marginal
del consumidor esto nos da un área como
un rectángulo bueno más bien como un
trapezoide si esta curva cumple como una
pendiente negativa en cualquier caso
podemos decir que el área debajo de la
curva de ganancia marginal del
consumidor es el beneficio en el mercado
derivado del consumo de en este caso
chocolate continuamos de esta manera si
cada vez hay más chocolate el mercado se
beneficiará pero la
ya no mostrará tanto entusiasmo tal vez
diga que viene de chocolate estaría bien
comer un poco más pero no necesito
demasiado y en algún punto la gente
puede hartarse del chocolate llegando a
un punto donde no habrá una ganancia
marginal del consumidor en esa cantidad
creciente de chocolate el chocolate
inundará la ciudad porque no habrá dónde
guardarlo pero no siempre ese es el caso
puede que conozcan un lugar así pero
cualquiera que sea la manera en que lo
piensen esta será nuestra curva de
ganancia marginal del consumidor
observen que esta gráfica es exactamente
igual que una curva de demanda en el
mercado de chocolate hemos trazado una
gráfica de precio y cantidad en el
mercado de chocolate pero hemos pensado
en ella en términos de ganancia marginal
del consumidor en cuanto a la oferta hay
una idea relacionada vamos a pensar en
el costo marginal supongamos que al
principio en este mercado no se produce
chocolate entonces un empresario
inteligente dice conozco algunas
personas que son adictas al chocolate y
que podrían beneficiarse
de esto voy a producir chocolate estas
personas salen a la calle y se
encuentran con que en la ciudad hay una
fábrica de chocolate abandonada nadie la
usa y está rodeada de arbustos de cacao
silvestre que son perfectos para
fabricar chocolate además en la ciudad
hay algunas personas que están
desempleadas pero que son asombrosas
fabricando chocolate en un principio el
costo marginal de producir las primeras
unidades de chocolate es bastante bajo
pero una vez que empezamos a utilizar a
esas personas la fábrica abandonada y
los arbustos de cacao tendremos que
plantar nuevos arbustos capacitar nuevos
empleados y construir una nueva fábrica
entonces producir unidades adicionales
de chocolate va a costar un poco más y
luego cada vez más esta es la tendencia
general en la mayoría de los mercados
al principio producimos la primera
cantidad de una manera barata usando lo
más posible los elementos que teníamos a
la mano pero luego vamos a necesitar más
factores de producción por lo que el
costo marginal por unidad será cada vez
más alto entonces qué fue lo que
construimos
podrán decir esa es una curva de costo
marginal pero no olviden que también
puede ser vista como la curva de oferta
de este mercado en particular ahora bien
qué sucede cuando producimos estas
cantidades bajas
digamos que producimos la cantidad del
taco el costo de producción será el área
debajo de la curva del costo marginal si
podemos vender esa cantidad la ganancia
del mercado será el área total debajo de
esta curva roja y si tenemos la ganancia
total del mercado podemos sacar el costo
entonces podemos decir que lo que
tenemos entre estas curvas es un
excedente de ganancia vamos a escribirlo
excedente de ganancia seguramente no han
escuchado este término pero a mí me
gusta usarlo porque hace que sepamos
inmediatamente de qué estamos hablando
entonces mientras haya excedente de
ganancia
los productores irán que bien puedo
producir esto a un costo bajo la gente
obtiene una gran ganancia y está
dispuesta a pagar 10 pesos por kilo de
cualquiera que sea mi producción si la
gente obtiene toda esta ganancia
definitivamente estará dispuesta a pagar
10 pesos por mi producto
entonces voy a producir un poco más y
voy a cobrar cualquier cantidad entre
estas áreas quizá pueda fijar mi precio
en este punto y así obtengo una parte de
la ganancia y los consumidores la otra
parte pero tal vez otro empresario se da
cuenta de que todavía hay más ganancias
que se pueden aprovechar en este mercado
así que continuarán produciendo mientras
la ganancia marginal del consumidor siga
siendo mayor que el costo marginal hasta
llegar a este punto que sucede cuando
llegamos a este punto bueno ya hablamos
de oferta y demanda y sabemos que estos
son el precio de equilibrio y la
cantidad de equilibrio pero pensemos en
que dijimos que hasta este punto tiene
sentido producir cada vez más incluso si
ya estamos en esta cantidad tiene
sentido producir un poco más porque
aunque vamos a incurrir en este costo el
consumidor va a tener toda esta ganancia
y vemos que es mayor el costo y tal vez
digan bueno mientras mi producto se
venda por un precio intermedio podemos
dividir este excedente de ganancia pero
una vez que estas dos líneas se
intersectan en este punto donde el
beneficio del consumidor
es igual al costo marginal del productor
ya no hay excedente de ganancia así que
en realidad ya no hay ningún incentivo
para producir más que esto más allá de
este punto el costo de producción
creciente el costo marginal es mayor que
la ganancia marginal del consumidor
entonces si quieren vender su producto
por la ganancia en realidad estarían
asumiendo una pérdida incluso si
pensamos en el mercado en sí la sociedad
estaría incurriendo en un costo por
unidad adicional el excedente de
ganancia no existiría entonces para qué
hacerlo hasta ahora hemos hablado de
este punto en el que se intersectan
estas dos curvas solo en términos de
oferta y demanda pero cuando hablamos en
términos de beneficio del consumidor
marginal y de costo marginal esta
cantidad que llamaremos q sub 0 se
considera una asignación eficiente suena
muy sofisticado asignación eficiente
bueno cualquier otra cantidad no sería
eficiente por ejemplo digamos que por
alguna razón nuestra cantidad es esta
que vamos a llamar 1 con esa cantidad la
ganancia marginal del consumidor es
mayor que el costo marginal
el mercado está dejando una gran
cantidad de excedente de ganancia o
excedente total sobre la mesa y esta
ganancia que el mercado podría haber
tenido pero que no tiene se llama
pérdida de eficiencia en la asignación
de los recursos hablamos de esto en
otros vídeos recuerden que para llegar a
la asignación eficiente de una cantidad
tenemos este gran excedente total que es
el área que está debajo de la curva de
beneficio del consumidor marginal y
encima de la curva del costo marginal
hasta el punto de intersección pero si
producimos una cantidad menor que la
asignación eficiente de la cantidad el
beneficio del consumidor marginal es
mayor que el costo marginal por lo que
estamos dejando todo este excedente
total en el mercado independientemente
de cómo podríamos haberlo asignado o
distribuido entre los consumidores o
productores y qué pasa si producimos una
cantidad mayor que la asignación
eficiente de la cantidad supongamos que
esto es q 2 entonces aquí tenemos un
costo marginal mayor que una ganancia
marginal por lo que vamos a crear
excedente negativo ahora en esta área
tenemos un excedente de ganancia
negativo
o mejor dicho un costo neto en el que el
mercado está incurriendo y esta era una
pérdida de eficiencia en la asignación
de los recursos porque estábamos dejando
sobre la mesa un excedente de ganancia
que podríamos haber aprovechado aquí
estamos produciendo un costo no sólo
nuestros productores están produciendo a
un costo y la ganancia que nuestros
consumidores están obteniendo es menor
por cada unidad adicional de hecho es
mucho menor que el costo por lo que
estamos incurriendo en un excedente de
ganancia negativo eso también se
considera una pérdida de la eficiencia
en la asignación de los recursos la cual
solemos asumir como la pérdida de una
parte del excedente total pero también
tenemos pérdida en la eficiencia en la
asignación de los recursos cuando
producimos innecesariamente porque la
ganancia del consumidor es menor que el
costo real entonces aunque el beneficio
del consumidor marginal sea mayor que el
costo marginal o como en este caso
aunque el costo marginal sea mayor que
el beneficio del consumidor marginal en
ambos casos vamos a producir pérdida de
eficiencia en un mundo ideal
con funcionamiento adecuado debería
producir una cantidad en la asignación
eficiente por supuesto todos nuestros
modelos dan por sentado muchas
suposiciones para hacer las cosas un
poco más sencillas y que podamos
entender el comportamiento del mercado
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo